.
Let's solve some of the issues you are dealing with
With a thin line
You may see that this means
Models of change, because we will formulate what
Described in this matter
We will represent him then I hope we are
We will be able to answer questions
Let's see what is required
The current standard for shower water flow is 2.5
Gallon / min
2.5 gallons / min
Calculate how long it takes to fill 30 gallons
The bathtub has a shower
Works to connect water
What can be done here is that we can put a model of change in order
So it looks excellent, and say okay
Let's put a small equation describing the number
The gallons you have filled in - or the number of gallons you have
We need to use it after a certain number of minutes
Let's assume that our gallons are equal to the ratio
What we have filled of gluons
If it equals 2.5 gallons / min ×
Number of minutes
× minutes
I will say that m is the minutes and g is the number of gallons
And we just have to put a paradigm shift
Nothing better than that
We now have a formula that describes - give me
The number of minutes, and I will hit it with 2.5
Because that way we will fill the bathtub quickly
After one minute, 1 x 2.5 = 2.5 gallons
After two minutes, we have 2 × 2.5 = 5 gallons
If this is the model
This is also a line
Remember the line equation model y = mx + b
We do not have b here
b does not exist
We only have m × x time
The x here is the minutes and y
The gallons are and the inclination is 2.5
Let us define it before answering the question
Instead of naming this x axis - remember that x
The independent variable, which is expressed as minutes
Which the water flows out
This axis m relative to the minutes
And the vertical axis, instead of being called y axis
I will call it a g-axis relative to the number of gallons
Which we fill
I will only solve the positive quarter, assuming it is
We only have positive minutes
What's going on?
Our inclination is 2.5
We can also write this as a gallon = -2.5
Equivalent 5/2 gallons / min × Number of minutes
Now we know that the tilt is 5/2
I use 2.5 as well, but I prefer 5/2
We know that the intersection of y is 0
We have no intersection y
You can write + 0 instead
Start here from the center
This is the y intersection
And for every 2 we move to the right, we will move by 5 to the top
If we move - change in x is 2
1,2,3,4,5
The change in x is 2
If the change in x is -2, then the change in y will be
1,2,3,4,5
And so on
We will be here
If the line, if we want to represent the model graphically it will look like this
I'm doing my best to order all these points
In fact, I said that I would only be there
In the first quarter
It is not logical to be present in this quarter
Because it can not get negative points
Or should not get negative minutes
You should only deal with them here
The question now is how long it takes to fill
30 gallons of bathtub?
Now, unfortunately, the graphic representation did not pass by
Road up to 30 gallons
If so - we have 10 gallons here
These are 10 gallons if you move up by 3, I can
Read the representation
But we can also find it algebraically
How many minutes does it take?
Well, let's make the gallons equal to 30
If we have 30 gallons = - I will write them
In the same color - 2.5 gallons / min × number of minutes
× Number of minutes
All we have to do now until we find the number of minutes is to divide
Both ends are at 2.5 gallons / min
Divide both sides at 2.5 gallons / min
2.5 gallons / min
I'm writing modules so I'll show you the modules
All will succeed in the end
If this is deleted
And we have 1 left
The left side - or we can say m--
Will equal 30 2.5 2.5
We have these gallons in place
Gallons
I want to see you, you can deal with the units like you
Dealing with actual numbers
If I had a gallon / min in the place, then
Divided into this pairing, this is equivalent
Beating in reverse
Equivalent multiplication
In minutes / gallons
Right?
These units were in place
When I put them in the rugs, I overturn them
If gallons are in rugs, the gallons are in place
Are deleted
I have 30 2.5 2.5 minutes remaining
How much is 30 2.5 2.5?
= 12
It will take us 12 minutes to fill 30 gallons of bathtub
We have minutes here
12 minutes
Let's solve another issue
Amen - or man, I do not know the best way up
The name is fuzzy - it uses a hose
The water hose is used to fill the new swimming pool
for the first time
It started at 10 am - let me write this down
It started at 10 am - this is the start time - and let it go
The water pumps the whole night
At 6 am, he measured depth only
The amount of water was filled 4/7 of the pond
When it started at 10 am - this time and that
What has been filled of pond
So, clearly when he started the pool was empty
It's a new pool
As we have given
If filling the pool is 0
It's 0
There is no water in the pond
Then at 6 am, Bassas did the depth and found the pond
Filled with 4/7
The amount of water is equal to 4/7
At what hour will his blessing be filled?
If we want to know when they are full
When is 1/1?
Or 7/7
At what time?
To do so, we have to develop a similar model as we did
The last time
We can say that filling the pond is equal
Fixed what amount of time it took
We know that when time is 0 - let me write it that way
This is the time
Let me write it here
This is the time, 0
How much is the hour?
It's been eight hours, is not it?
These are 8 hours
We do not know what it is
This is another time
When the time is 0 at 10 am, 0 × k, we have 0 filled
M is filled
When the time is 8, we have k × 8. Where k kicks off the ratio
Which we fill with blessing
k × 8
It was filled 4/7
Now we can find the value of k
We can find a constant ratio
Of the paradigm of change
All I said is, look, this
Fill the pond because it can be formulated using
Equation is so
The quantity we fill is directly proportional to
The amount of time the water hose is allowed to pump
This is the constant seed
We do not know how fast it fills them, but we can now find
This speed
Because we know that after 8 hours it will be filled with 4/7
Until k, we divide both sides by 8 hours
We get k = 4/7 8 8 hours, what
Equivalent to 4/7 × 1/8 water / hour quantity
If we find this, let me see
Divide on 4
We get the amount of water equal to 1/14
It's a rather odd unit - the amount of water / hour
Or you can say, we have filled 1/14 of the pool / hour
If k = 1/14
If the equation - let me write it here
Fill the pond = 1/14 × time
So the equation we have to answer is when
This equals 1?
At what time?
Let's put the equation
We have 1
This means that we filled it completely
= 1/14 × time
If we hit the two ends of equation B14
Then 1/14 and 14 will be deleted
Our remaining t = 14
If the pool is full after 14 hours
Remember that everything we dealt with was in the hours unit
If we start at 10 am - time is 0 - how long will it be
When 14 hours pass?
10 am on the first day - if we go to 10 am the next day
This is 12 hours
So I think
We need to go for another couple of hours to get 14 hours
The next afternoon
The pool will be full
We can represent this
I have this datasheet here
Let us represent everything I talk about
The equation - I wrote it here - fills the pond =
1/14 × t
Let's assume that each age is about 2
Where it is 2,4,6,8,10,12,14
This shows that as we move by 14, we will rise by 1
If the change in x is 14, the change in y is positive 1
I will make these units 1,2
Staging is not excellent
I distort the graph a bit, but this 1
If the graphic representation will look like this
So
The tilt is 1/14
Anyway, I hope you found this ground useful
.